Tucker Carlson had a rather quick
snippet that I thought was pretty solid
on this as far as we know no one's ever
addressed the United States Congress in
a sweatshirt before but they love him
much more than they love you
like that's just true these people who
are giving your money to this guy who
are giving him standing ovations
uh they do love him more than they love
you that's unfortunate and by the way
that's bipartisan you know my line about
how you can't be a republican you can't
be a Democrat right you cannot be a
Democrat maybe you should be a
republican maybe you should be but
they're going to fail you too right
that's how it is that's just how it is
and we're seeing that right now that
being said there are a few Republicans
doing some nice work on this Mike Lee is
trying to stop this crazy Omnibus Bill
we've had Rand Paul obviously fighting
against it uh Ted Cruz like there are a
couple people Marco Rubio they are
realizing that we cannot endlessly uh
fight uh we cannot endlessly fund this
thing John Kennedy from Louisiana I've
got some video of him in just a second
and a bunch more